okay so obviously this is gonna have
spoilers so spoiler alert ahead of time
before I even talk about anything um a
vendor's endgame this movie I was not
prepared this movie was emotional it was
an emotional roller coaster
um again split so like if so you if you
complain about spoilers in this video
like if you if you jump in the comments
if you complain about spoilers we're all
just gonna laugh at you because you were
told ahead of time there were spoilers
um
the death of Ironman was crazy
um and honestly I thought Captain
America was gonna die I was so sure cap
was gonna die I thought they were gonna
keep Robert Downey jr. going because of
like because Robert Downey jr. he's like
I can make an infinite amount of money
by being in the in the moral Cinematic
Universe the death of Black Widow like
she's not coming back she's gone forever
her soul was exchanged for the soul
stone so she's in the afterlife gone
gone gone gone gone the only way they
can get her back I don't know if the MCU
will do this the only way they can get
her back is they would have to travel to
the realm of mistress death and barter
for her soul and get her and get her
back that way it'd be the only way to
really do it ah but the the movie was
was it was everything I'd hoped it would
be and here's a cool thing watching the
movie it feels like the finality right
like they could stop here and just be
like and now we're done we're no longer
making any comic book films like like it
it felt that way to a degree but the
cool thing about it is that it does
continue on now here's an important
thing this is this really the thing that
like everybody missed right now I feel
like so many people missed this so the
big talking point with with with
Avengers in game is the idea of like
multiverses right so those you guys who
aren't familiar with this um the Marvel
Cinematic Universe uses Marvel Comics
branch universe theory right what that
means is that there there is a singular
timeline and then the Marvel Cinematic
Universe right so we can say that all
the events that we've seen in the MCU
every single event that's ever taken
place from Peggy Carter to Captain
America to you know iron man and all
that kind of good stuff all the movies
we've seen are all along this main
timeline and the way this plays out is
that you can travel you can jump back
and forth in different locations and you
can basically shift things up right so
like like what if Tony Stark never
became Iron Man right like there's a
universal
that happens you have to have a cause
you have to have something that
instigates that but like Howard Stark
never dies Tony Stark never takes over
the like likes it's it never happened so
you go all the way back right say Bucky
Barnes never fell off the train in
Captain America the First Avenger
and so Bucky Barnes was never frozen in
ice he was never discovered by the
Russians and he was never turned into
the Winter Soldier if he was never
turned into the Winter Soldier that
means that Howard Emery astark never
died which means Tony Stark never
inherited his father's company as young
as you did and then he never became Iron
Man what you did because there was no
reason for him to write like being the
head of a company that was creating
weapons it was killing me killing
innocent people that led him to become
Iron Man if his parents never died that
never becomes the case so like that
singular act branches off a whole nother
universe where things progressed
accordingly so you have a model
Cinematic Universe where Tony Stark
never became Iron Man if Tony Stark
never became Iron Man he was never
approached by Nick Fury for the Avengers
initiative because he was never
approached by Nick Fury the Avengers
were never formed like there's there's
all kinds of things that didn't come out
of that now from that alternate reality
then there's other alternate realities
what happens if Tony Stark ends up
becoming Iron Man in that alternate
universe but he's a bad guy but he
becomes a villain right he works
alongside the Mandarin or becomes the
new Mandarin you know what if like he
takes the extremest tech it drives him
crazy and then he wipes out humanity I
mean there's all kinds of difference and
although there's a play out in that but
the gist of Avengers in game was they
said okay us traveling back into the
past
taking the Infinity stones from where
they were bring them to the present day
snapping our fingers and fixing
everything is gonna create an alternate
reality it's gonna create an alternate
universe the only way to basically fix
that is to take the Infinity stones and
put them back where they were before the
moment they were taken and so in a sense
they basically fixed the present and the
past
at the same time and it creates a loop
right there it's a-- it creates a loop
that's not a paradox because the
question that you would ask is if they
travel from the present into the past to
get the Infinity stones in order to fix
the present but then the pres like
everything is basically undone
then what motivation would they have in
the first place where they fix that by
basically saying like yes this happened
we're not stopping Thanos before the
snap we're undoing the snap therefore
everything from infinity wars still
progress the way it was supposed to
there's no paradox there and so if you
were to if you if Scott Lang or whoever
we're to hop into the timestream and
literally ride that that that quantum
world wave all the way through to the
present day they would count they would
see if they if you did it like a million
times he would see the exact same events
take place everything in the MCU happens
up until infinity war the leftover of
Enders go into the past take the
Infinity stones come back to the present
undo the snap and then drop them off
from the past again that's the nature of
of how this film unfolds here's the
thing everybody missed the timeline was
not fixed the timeline was not corrected
the timeline is still screwed up and
Captain America's the one who broken and
here's the reason why the idea behind
this was that everything basically it
was it was like it was a sneak mission
but it was like how Scott Lang Pirela
Scott Scott Lang said it a time heist
they had to sneak in get the Infinity
stones and leave without anybody knowing
so no one would know that they were
there they wouldn't conflict with their
past versions so nobody could could know
what was going on now for the most part
a lot of that stuff was sorted out right
like Tony talked to his father Howard
but Howard had no idea that it was his
son Captain America ended up fighting
himself and then you used the mind stone
to wipe his mind so like you you have
like these things were was basically
sorted out the ancient one wasn't going
to tell anybody because the ancient one
was well enough to basically know hey
look if I tell people it's gonna crude
script timestream so I'm not gonna tell
anybody that I talked to banner like
natasha romanoff died but I mean you
know like her death not that it was
meaningless but nobody else knew about
it except for Clint Barton and and the
other Avengers so it's not like it
impacted the Greater timeline and she
was essentially uh she was a hole in the
universe right like she had no family
she had friends but that was basically
and she didn't have any kids she was
leaving behind or anything like that and
even if she did they could just rock it
up and say well she died in the
banishing when half the life in the in
the universe was wiped out and she got
dusted like everybody else there's a
zillion ways I could write it out but
they were supposed to sneak in a sneak
out no one was supposed to know that
were there fix everything and then sneak
back drop everything off and then sneak
back out again but Captain America
changed it because the reason why was
that at the end of the film when Captain
America was basically given the Infinity
stones and them said hey look your job
is to go into the past to drop them off
to where they're supposed to be and then
come back he did he stayed and the fact
that he stayed changed everything
because the entire basis behind the
formation of shield SSR like Peggy
Carter
Chester Phillips all those guys was all
based on the notion
the Captain America was believed to have
been dead trying to create a better
world in the name of Captain America was
their motivation for doing everything
they did but if Captain America didn't
die what motivation Rafi wasn't believed
to have been dead what motivation do
they have now what this does is it
basically opens the floodgates for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe to do anything
they want to now because essentially
what they've done is is because my
thought going into this was okay she
they basically wrote themselves into a
whole in terms of bringing anybody else
in right like bringing all these other
characters and bring in the x-men
different things like that how do they
possibly do it if anything it makes my
theory work even better on how they
unlike at least my plan on how they
could roll the x-men in them because if
Captain America goes into the past he
stays with Peggy Carter he has a life
with her she inevitably develops
Alzheimer's she has up passing away and
then Captain America is sitting there on
the in front of the lake with like Sam
Wilson and and Bruce Banner and then I'm
sorry yeah Sam Wilson Bruce Banner Bucky
Barnes and then give Sam Wilson the
shield and says you're the new Captain
America now like what that basically
means is he outlived Peggy but he had
that life with her presumably they had
no children there's no reason for us to
believe that they did because if they
did we probably would have seen it so in
that regard Captain America was probably
careful insofar as like I don't want to
screw up the timestream I don't really
know how that conversation unfolds hey
Steve do you want to have children one
day
well Peggy I would love to but I'm
technically from the future and if I did
it would screw up the time stream okay
love like I have no idea how that
conversation what unfold but but still
what this means is that the motivation
for why things happen the way they did
with regards to the SSR and shield have
changed dramatically we know that like
Nick Fury like like not invested with
Nick Fury in them it's all for so pretty
much the same it's not like Nick Fury
wasn't there we saw him at the funeral
of Tony Stark right so like that told us
everything we needed to knows you know
like Nick Fury still becomes director of
shield the cool thing about this and the
reason why this is so important is all
the things we don't see we don't know
what Steve Rogers did with SSR we don't
know if Steve Rogers told him hey look
so like hydras basically operating
inside you guys and like that guy right
there is the one who's leading it so
take him out and everything will be okay
like we don't know if he was doing
anything like that we don't know if I
mean because here's here's the thing and
I've been saying this I have
the literature sauna I've been saying
that I've been Smith huh and hi I've
been saying this for a while here is the
thing Wolverine give us wolf brain and
just say that Wolverine is just like a
project of Sheol or Hydra or whatever
but like literally wait like you can
unfold that any number of ways you can
say that like because of the fact that
Captain America was there now like
shield took more of a direction where it
was more conducive to how Captain
America envisioned it or how shield was
supposed to be without Hydra being in
there but you can still say that like
there's there were little black ops
missions and things like that you can
literally say like Captain America was
the one who recruited James Howlett to
bring him in in order to turn them into
Wolverine there's there's infinite
possibilities now there's no limit to
what they can do and it's so cool
because like that it's a different
timeline now it's essentially a
different timeline everything's
basically changed now and that's that's
what's so cool is because it kind of
ends on the note of no everything's fine
everything's still basically the same
but that's the way the multiverse works
it's like in the end like people
perceive the Marvel multiverse in this
in this idea of like so every universe
is drastically different right I mean
like like look at infinity world right
like people were looking at Infinity
Ward and they said the 14 million
possibilities of Doctor Strange looked
at like they're they're all like just
like these drastically different things
nothing about this it's a multiverse an
infinite number of universes for an
infinite number of possibilities it just
happens to be that only those 14 million
universes pertains to like the events
unfolding with the Avengers finding
Thanos there's a universe out there
where Thanos shows up on earth and
joined the Avengers there's a universe
where Thanos joins of guardians of the
galaxy there's there's a universe out
there where Adam warlock wakes up
earlier and then he gets the Infinity
Gauntlet it wipes out half light White's
not half light the universe there's a
there's a universe out there where
nebula gets the Infinity Gauntlet and
there's a universe out there where
Thanos was never born or Gamora killed
him when she was in her younger years
and basically got the Infinity Gauntlet
herself there's all different kinds of
universes out there right and so because
that the some of the changes in these
universes are huge or a massive and some
of the changes are miniscule like you
end up having a Peter Parker who joins a
Future Foundation instead of joining
Peter joining Tony Stark
the Future Foundation was the think tank
that was created by Reed Richards or
Peter Parker joins joins horizon labs in
max Modell instead of like like you know
story and
um if there's there's all these
different different things out there
just because things look the same does
not mean they are the same that they
could be like totally different and they
are Captain America is staying in the
past and living a life with Peggy Carter
changes everything and and how far that
change goes we won't really know it
could be that like everything is the
same now accepted like now Wolverines on
the scene or like now Deadpool's here
like there's they can literally use that
as a means to say like here's everything
Captain America did and here's how it
all ties into how things are supposed to
be versus how things are now it's an
awesome concept right it's a it's a
really really cool concept so it's one
of the things that people tend to forget
did you know not every timeline is
starkly different you know some stores
some timelines are very very very very
similar right like in the end in which
you makalah in Marvel Comics you've got
a timeline what is it in the main Marvel
Universe Jean Grey became became the
Dark Phoenix alright
everything inverses there's an alternate
reality where everything happened the
exact same way but the only difference
is that Jean Grey stays crazy and
destroys the universe and that's it I'll
shoot of surprises power wipes
everything out and that's that's the
only difference it's a big difference
but it's the only difference but
everything else had happened up to that
point was exactly identical that one
thing made the difference and that's all
it ever takes right that's all it ever
takes for that scenario and we see that
play out in comics all the time like in
Doomsday Clock kind of sight reading
from the MCU for over like two seconds
and Doomsday Clock dr. Manhattan moved
the Green Lantern out of reach for Alan
Scott and so Alan Scott gets hit by a
train and the Justice Society of America
never gets swarmed like it's the exact
same thing also Maddy had to do like
Captain America could have gone back and
like misplace the keys of Stephen
strange like moves them to a different
location and like it takes him five
extra seconds to find his keys and that
five extra seconds makes a difference
between him getting in a car wreck and
him not getting in a car line like
that's all that ever takes that's all
that ever takes and Captain America
going into the past
staying in the past living a full life
of Peggy Carter Chester Phillips and all
those guys knowing he's alive basically
changes everything now it's it's so cool
so we are in an alternate reality like
we're in an alternate universe now this
is not the same Marvel Cinematic
Universe as it was before there's no way
it can be because things are changed and
it didn't happen the exact same way it
did before it happened the exact same
way as it did before
except that Captain America State and
it's not a small thing it's only a Scott
leg right I mean Scott Lang's cool and
everything but if he decided to say into
the past it probably wouldn't really
matter that much but Captain America was
it like his perceived death was a major
driving force for pretty much the entire
intelligence and like military arm of of
the United States right because you had
the strategic science reserve and then
shield was formed later on and then
she'll absorbed the SSR and everything
the SSR had developed all went forward
as a singular shield entity but all that
was predicated on Captain America that
the perceived death of Captain America
so again it's it's cool and it's really
really wild and it's Polly awesome but I
absolutely loved in-game oh my god I
loved I loved in-game I loved her so
much that that movie I'll probably go
see it again like at some point that
movie was nuts it was it was so cool it
was really really long but it didn't
feel exceedingly long it felt like there
was like everything was a port I love
the first court like the first third of
the film oh god it was at the saddest
thing ever it's just like everybody's
like moping around and they're like yes
we're all basically screwed there's like
a five-year gap and I was like Judas and
I called it all right there were so many
things I was sitting in the movie I was
watching kid was myself it was comic
story in Dan the editor it was Harry the
camera guy it was Huston bindis brother
Andy it was DJ the personal trainer of
like Vinny and all them like and then
like myself and Mariah and we were we
were we were leaving the theater we were
coming back MRI was like I was kind of
amazed that like pretty much everything
that happened in that movie you call and
I was like I read comic sweetheart like
they're not doing anything that I
haven't seen in the college before or at
least having read comics for so long
after a while you can kind of hang on
small thing there were there were some
things I got wrong I mean I'm not a guru
I don't know everything but like it was
looking us you know so it's it's it's
it's cool like the movie was the movie
was the movie was fantastic it was it
was
it's the best come a book movie today
that's a cool thing it didn't even
really feel like a comic book movie but
like it just felt like a movie where
like things were popping off and like it
was really dark like pg-13 it was
borderline r-rated if I'm being honest
with you guys like like sure it was
pg-13 but like they push the envelope
more than a few times in that in that
film but dude it was oh my god it was it
was it was phenomenal if you're on the
fence about Avengers in game do not be
like buy a ticket for whatever showings
available in two weeks because you're
not gonna buy one anytime soon buy it to
you for whatever showings available in
two weeks and go watch it because it is
it is amazing like it's absolutely it's
absolutely phenomenal but yeah basically
we're in an alternate universe now
Captain America is a reason why and this
give them the ability to kind of explore
things right because this is cool
Captain America being alive now it's
like hey look like on the off chance of
something like this because here's
here's a here's a beers a big thing they
can come out this here's one of the
biggest things that can come out of this
right like Captain America goes back and
says hey look so like there's you know
like we're only one planet and this huge
you know infinitely expanding universe
don't you guys think we should have some
sort of system that like monitors space
and so then we get sort and like
literally that's all it takes
it's a bug that Captain America plants
that someone easier and so in the
present day swords out there you just
got a sword satellite just sitting out
there the sentient world observation and
response department just monitoring
space just keeping an eye on things you
know it's it's it's there's so many
things that you can bring out it has
sold so many little small things you can
do with this but yeah it's it's the one
thing everybody forgets so without being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come
let's explain makes you guys have the
sub button to become part of the rob4 if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop on like and I will catch you
all later peace
[Music]